All right.
I'm going to have to sort of issue an apology
here.
We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
I am causing huge problems for one of our
viewers with his fiancee.
Take a listen to this.
Hey, David.
My name's Danny.
This is the first time I'm calling in.
But I've been a listener for a few years now.
And I was really just calling to ask kindly
for you to dial back on the reasonable and
wise takes.
Right.
It's starting to cause some jealousy issues
with my fiancee that I listen to so often.
So sorry.
And not only politics, but also your assessment
of pies and apple pies especially.
Right.
I think the only major disagreement I've had
lately has been with your take on sweet potatoes
as, quote, the perfect vegetable.
In fact, I submit to you that, in fact, bell
peppers are that perfect.
Oh, my God.
Clean them out.
You can eat them like an apple.
They taste great.
They're not annoyingly spicy.
They're crispy.
You can stuff them and bake them.
Oh, dear.
Anyways, I just need for you to dial back
on the stellar opinion pieces you're handing
out media literacy like it's candy on Halloween.
And you're also the biggest reason I voted.
I was I'm a very supporter, but that's about
it.
Biden, thank you.
So for the sake of my happily ever after,
would you please just cut it out?
Yeah.
Listen, I apologize that your fiance is getting
jealous and all of that, but so hear a bell.
Pepper is is better than a sweet potato.
And I'm not anti bell pepper in any way.
But but when you're cooking, you dip, you
dip a bell pepper in some hummus.
That's great.
But in cooking a peno, OK, you're adding a
little heat.
But a bell pepper is not dramatically different
than an onion in that it gets soft and absorbs
the flavor of whatever is there.
Sweet potato brings so much more to the table
from the standpoint of flavor, from the standpoint
of nutrition, from the standpoint of caloric
density.
And I just read a fascinating I have loved
sweet potatoes since I was a little kid when
I was first sampling baby food back in 1984,
I guess eighty five now.
Eighty four would have been, um, when I first
got my first taste of sweet potato, my eyes
lit up.
It was it was an incredible day.
And, you know, a lot of people think because
a sweet potato has the word potato in it,
that it's it's like a potato.
It has nothing to do with the potato.
Understand that potatoes are the stems of
a plant, whereas sweet potatoes are the root
or as some say, the root.
I say root the it's a totally different family.
It is a potato and a sweet potato could not
be more different.
And by the way, all these people in the U.S.
who interchangeably talk about a sweet potato
and a yam, I don't know that I've ever seen
a yam, an actual yam in the United States.
Yams are gigantic compared to sweet potatoes.
They look different.
Let's stop mis naming sweet potatoes as yams.
Anyway, I could go on for probably an hour
about sweet potatoes, but the mere idea that
a bell pepper is going to hold a candle to
sweet potatoes, I find that offensive.
But otherwise, I love the praise.
I love that this caller voted thanks to the
show, et cetera, et cetera.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We'll talk about Rudy Giuliani's slippery
cell phone.
We will talk about the Vatican's position
on vaccines for the virus that use abortion.
Cell lines hint they're OK with it.
And Deborah Brooks is going.
Bye bye when Joe Biden transitions in because
she's retiring.
And we'll talk about what we think is behind
that.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom and get instant
access to the bonus show.